bonjour ici sébastien desrosiers en ce
début de campagne électorale fédérale
voyage à bord de l'autobus du bloc
québécois alors à quoi ça ressemble une
caravane en pleine pandémie bien tous
les matins on doit remplir un
questionnaire sur notre état de santé
pour s'assurer qu'on n'a pas de
symptômes évidemment de l'accord et 19
avant de monter à bord port du masque
bien sûr alors un abord les places sont
limitées seulement une dizaine de
personnes se trouvent sur cette caravane
qui doivent présenter une preuve de
double vaccination vous voyez entre les
rangées de sièges se trouvent des
feuilles de plastique alors cette
organisation du travail des
rassemblements moins fréquents font
partie d'une nouvelle réalité pour les
habitués de cet exercice malgré tout à
tous je vous souhaite une bonne campagne